[Music]
we're continuing our partnership with
learn liberty this week and joining me
today as a senior fellow at the Mercatus
Center at George Mason University as
well as a professor of economics at
George Mason Don Boudreau welcome to the
Reuben report happy to be here I am glad
you are here I saw you speak about a
year ago in Dallas I want to get the
exact title of the speech right it was
called can we bring sound economic
thinking to Washington that's a tough
task that was a year ago and I don't
think there's much sound economic
thinking or sound thinking in Washington
forget economics for a second these
things don't seem to go together these
days Washington seems to repel something
and it's it's a it's it attracts unsound
thinking yeah well you think it was
always that way or are we in unique time
well we're definitely in unique town
we're unique time so you know I was born
in 1958 so I came of age right when
Ronald Reagan write that you know the
end of the Carter Administration when
even Carter is pushing for directly
accepting deregulation taxes were being
cut airline to being deregulated Surface
Transportation is being deregulated
Reagan gets elected in 1980 Milton
Friedman it has this popular show on PBS
called free to choose Thomas I'll learn
about Thomas soul everything seems very
this world's fine yeah and so in my life
in my life
there was a period in the past when this
thinking was more sound I could quibble
with it yeah but compared to today it
was it was outstanding because it's
definitely it's definitely declined yeah
it's hard to imagine even that around a
time of Jimmy Carter that deregulation I
mean that that Democrats could have had
anything to do with that and yet they
Ted Kennedy was a major force behind
airline deregulation so it was something
it was something I'm not sure what it
was exactly it was something in the air
yeah starting in the late 70s and so you
know I was a young man and I just
thought it took for granted all right
this is fine you know we're winning and
then it culminates in 1989 with the
collapse of the of the of the
Iron Curtain in 1991 the collapse the
Soviet Union and then here we are 2018
and a lot of nonsense is back on the
front burner nonsense is back so let's
jump back though to the 70s for a second
because I watched an interview with you
this morning something happened to you I
believe in 1977 that that woke you up
and I think it sort of is a nice entry
into everything else that you know I
know yeah the most important day what
happened to you in 1977 you can come up
with a couple options now no I don't
date was was January 24th 1977 I
remember it was a I I was in college
only to please my mother my plan was to
drink beer chase girls I did a lot of
the former I wasn't successful with the
latter but I was then I was going to
drop out of college and work at the
shipyard where my parents worked so I
needed a class to fit my schedule I
needed the Monday Wednesday Friday class
so I think this class called economics
didn't know what it was took it and I
had a great teacher and so she drew
supply demand curves on the board she
said look what happens when the
government prevents the price of
something from rising to its market
level it creates a shortage
she says you remember the gasoline
shortages of 1973 yeah I was in those
and I just thought the beauty of this
economic explanation for the gasoline
shortage was so spectacular I wanted to
learn more about the subject and so in
very short order I just fell in love
with economics I'm still in love with it
to this day yeah so tell me what
happened after that so now you have your
spark and what what sort of what
academic pursuits did you have that got
you to where you are well I was very
lucky again she was a really good
teacher and it wasn't a famous economist
at all but she was a very good teacher
she took a great interest in her
students she taught economics as if it
was something relevant to the real world
rather than just a mathematical puzzle
and there was another guy at my so I
went splits called Nicholls State
University in Thibodaux Louisiana it's a
very small school but I had another
professor there who was into Milton
Friedman into Hayek into Ludwig von
Mises into James Buchanan who later
became my colleague at George Mason so
are we go to his office his name's bill
field and he would give me these books
and so I remember just rictus
tearing through these books and it just
made so much sense to me I realized in
reading these books that all my life I
didn't give much thought to politics not
much conscious thought but all my life I
think somewhere deep inside of me was a
classical liberal or libertarian someone
who believed it is it basically impolite
to button to other people's business and
and and and and not only impolite
Minister it's downright it's downright
offensive to do so yeah you just said
two of my buzz phrases so classical
liberal and libertarian now one of the
questions I get most because I define I
say that I am a classical liberal if I
need a look if I need a label on it
that's what I am and people will always
say to me because I talk about many of
the things that you teach about about
free markets and all that stuff and I
believe that freedom is the best way for
humans to flourish
people will say Dave you're really a
libertarian you're just holding on to
this definition of liberalism from a
teen whatever yeah do you see a
meaningful how would you define each one
and do you see a meaningful distinction
I don't see much of a distinction
depends on who you talk to some people
see see distinctions I think what they
both have in common may be distinctions
at the margin libertarians maybe tend to
be a little bit more radical but what
distinguishes classical liberals and
libertarians as I have broadly from
almost any other political group is the
consistent believe that any exercise of
power by the state must meet a huge
burden of proof the the the burden of
proof is not upon the individual to make
the case for his or her freedom its upon
the state to make the case to introdu to
override that freedom and I believe in
libertarians classical liberals as I
think of them believe that that burden
is a real one and it's a heavy one
sometimes it can be met but too often
the reverse is in place people believe
that you have to that the burden is on
those of us who who defend freedom to
make the case for freedom and I think
it's backwards so basically you view it
as sort of a bottom-up way of looking at
things yes right it's it's about the
individual first and the government is
not giving you your freedom it can take
it away however
by instituting all sorts of policies
yeah I'm in this case I am uh I think
John walke was right and John Locke
wasn't the only president John Locke
most famously made the argument in this
in the secondary is in government that
you know human beings have rights and
human beings delegate to the government
powers that you that that those who do
the delegation believe are appropriate
for the government to defend those
rights we can quibble about how
historically accurate that is but I like
I think that perspective is
philosophically correct right no
government gives me or you rights
governments are excellent at offending
rights it's taking them away but but
just because government is the protector
of Rights doesn't mean it gives us
rights just because farmers because we
couldn't live without farmers if no one
grew food and and and and didn't
ranching we would all starve that
doesn't mean that we owe our lives to
farmers one of the great things about
the society that we live in is that it's
a it's what Hayek all the great society
to be distinguished from Lyndon
Johnson's Great Society and that is it
is a society of many many individuals
each specialized in in doing various
things we're all coordinated by the
price system and by the rule of law and
so each of us makes a contribution to
the welfare of others but no one of us
is utterly essential and that's a that's
an it's a really good system I believe
yeah so I want to talk more about Hayek
in a little bit because you do run the
cafe Hayek blog
you mentioned the burden of proof that
the government has to meet to say when
it's right to actually infringe on some
of your rights or basically do things
yeah so this is where I would say the
the classical liberal and the
libertarian positions are a little bit
different I see some utility for the
state although I'd usually want it done
at the at the state level not the
federal level and libertarians it's sort
of hard to pin on when it's enough and
you you alluded to that when you talk to
libertarians how do you get to a place
where where it's not you know I always
make a joke it's like eventually you'll
just be in Mad Max or
the true anarcho-capitalists which I
enjoy talking to but I view it as more
of an intellectual exercise than a
practical yeah I'm very sympathetic to
anarcho-capitalism philosophically yeah
but I'm not a I'm not a blow things up
kind of guy I'm way too much of a
Hayekian to understand that you just
can't replace social institutions
wholesale society has to evolve to
wherever it's going to be if that just
remarks from being a realist I mean you
could blow it up well yes you could but
but history has a lot of really telling
examples about attempts to blow up
societies wholesale and those examples
have never turned out well right in
practice let me say among the people who
will call themselves classical liberals
right
none of them or ever whatever has
expressed any sympathy for Hanako
capitalism among libertarians some of
them will say oh no I believe there's a
role for the government but you do it
people who classify themselves
libertarian so who say at least at least
in principle I believe that a society
could exist without any formal
institution of monopolized coercion and
I am in that ladder ladder yeah I might
be the one classical liberal who will do
it or maybe that Canady by that
definition I'm a little more against
things yeah you know it's really sort of
the narcissism of small differences it
exactly in this little place all right
so what are some of the basic principles
you're a professor what are the basic
principles that people should know about
economics I know I'm giving you a wide
one there but someone watching this that
that's waiting for their 1977 moment
yeah so in no particular order right
number one
scarcity is unavoidable we live in a
world of scarce resources which means
that if you use some resources to do
this good thing you take resources away
from the ability to do other good things
they're both good things but we have to
choose do we want to do this good thing
I do we want to do that good thing
second thing to note in order to make
that decision we want the people
involved who are going to be affected
both by the loss of that which is not
done and by the benefit of that which is
done to express their opinions honestly
how valuable is this thing that we
propose to do and how
valuable is this thing that we propose
to give up in order to do this first
thing and and to do that we you you need
people on the ground who are actually
affected by these decisions to have a
meaningful say you don't want a third
party looking down making declarations
oh I think you should have that and I
think you should not have have that so
any social mechanism that gives each of
us as much of a say as possible in how
we use resources and and and make the
evaluations about what would what will
happen if we use resources in this way
and what will give up if we use
resources in this way that that's
important unintended consequences is
another important concept you know I had
Adam Smith in the wealth of nations
which is rightly considered to be the
start starting point of modern
scientific economics he famously talked
about the invisible hand and this is a
is a sort of an unintended consequences
kind of explanation it's not from the
benevolence of the butcher the brewer
their Baker that we expect our dinner
but from their regard to their own
interest they they don't dislike you
they value as a customer but they are
doing their jobs not primarily to help
you they're doing their jobs to help
themselves and you are buying from them
not primarily to help them but primarily
to help you and your family and in that
way everyone's a better so this is a
good unintended consequence but you have
you have bad unintended consequences as
well one of my favorite examples of a
bad unintended consequence is the
minimum wage you raise the minimum wage
it looks like you're helping low-skilled
workers and you might help some of them
but in fact you're putting other
low-skilled workers out of jobs and
you're keeping them out of the job
market for longer and so economists I
think what makes a good economist which
distinguishes a good economist from a
bad economist or non economist is is a
consistency in asking questions always
asking as compared to what as compared
to what where did that come from how are
you going to pay for that what did this
cost what will be the long-term
consequences down the road beyond the
immediate ones that that everyone can
see so it's just it's just a consistency
and asking those questions you know it's
funny as you're answering the question
and it keeps making me think well this
shows you why politics is so screwed up
because they get up there all
politicians on either side and they
either say $15 minimum wage Bernie or
Trump I'm gonna cut taxes on you or they
you know they love their bumper sticker
stuff yeah but nobody's ever said
unintended consequences in a
presidential debate
so how frustrating must that be as an
economist listening to people who are
not economists who really aren't experts
in much of anything
I don't know that Bernie's ever created
a business or made it anyone make a
dollar off him I'm not aware of it right
but but that must be incredibly
frustrating to hear non pros talk about
the things that you're a pro it is David
you know it's especially frustrating
about it it's not rocket science
I mean I mean I love economics I love my
profession and I really admire the best
among my professional colleagues Milton
Freeman Hayek but it's not rocket
science it's just this consistency of
always understanding that there are
consequences beyond the immediate that
that there's always a cost to something
that no matter how beneficial something
is it has to be weighed against that
cost so these simple the simple
understanding and the consistency in
applying that understanding it's not
difficult but so few people do it so it
is it is frustrating you years ago I
stopped a joke that I stopped watching
the evening people my age used to watch
the evening evening news stop watching
the news I've always threatened to throw
my shoes yeah through the through the
screen because you know the the
reporters they would very much like the
politicians they would report on the
immediate effect oh the minimum wage is
going to rise that that means that
workers will get a raise of you know
whatever the amount is well no it does
it it means that for some workers but it
means also other workers are going to
lose their jobs
some jobs the nature those jobs are
going to change employers aren't just
gonna sit back and say oh well we've got
to pay higher minimum wages so let's
just pay higher minimum wage where's
that money coming from where are those
resources coming from they have to come
from somewhere yeah so basically your
would be that the government's only role
in the economy is to make sure we're not
killing each other pretty much right
like it really it's a total lazy fair if
yes I am a very least if you're a guy if
if property rights are well-defined and
secure and there's a strong case of
government plays a role or can play a
role in helping to define and certainly
helping to secure property rights so
that's where your contract rights right
so that's where you're not in a narco
capitalist right well I'm close to being
here I mean III I'm willing I'm willing
to admit
we're grudgingly giving that to that I'm
willing yes I'm willing to admit that
anarcho-capitalism you know might not be
a Altima defensible position I am not
willing to admit that free markets are
an indefensible position however
property rights come to be however they
are defined however they are enforced
when you have secured private property
rights and freedom of contract which
includes importantly the freedom to say
no right I freed them to not contract
then people are led to pursue there are
people in pursuing their own interests
or obliged to help others out and that's
how this great society that we live in
and it is great continues to grow and
become more prosperous yeah so I
mentioned you right before we started
that you know I've had a political
awakening of sorts and I always say to
people I didn't really move but the left
went so bananas I ended up being friends
with all these libertarians and
conservatives or whatever it whatever it
is even for the differences we may have
but one place I have shifted is that I
am much more where you are economically
now and partly that's because I now run
my own business and have employees and
have to deal with that and I just wrote
two obscenely high checks for taxes for
the year I mean we are in California you
don't want to know how much that one was
and the federal loans even worse and
it's like you're more successful I get
the harder I work the more they want to
take from you and I tweeted something
about that on tax day and a lot of
people were angry at me and said well
it's it's this is the price to pay for
success would you rather be poor and I
didn't want to go on a major tweet storm
and
you wisely are not on Twitter but could
you could you give me something that if
I ever get in that fight again I can say
to people why that's not the right way
to think so let me start off though we
just asked you have you heard the the
story about George McGovern when he
retired from politics he makes no please
so George McGovern he retired from
politics I think I have the details
right he certainly had the major part of
it right he started the B&B you know in
his home state already like where this
is going
yeah and then he encounters all these
regulations you know labor regulations
safety regulations and he admits I can't
run out to whom he admitted is a long
time ago yeah he admits he's you know
I've spent all my I'm not quoting him
I'm yeah going from memory so I spent
all my life pushing for these things I
wasn't sufficiently attentive to the
downside of these taxes and these
regulations yeah and it's easy just you
know to sit in Sacramento to sit in
Washington DC to sit in some you know
local government office building and
tell other people how to live and to
tell other people how much money they
have to give to you and you can be well
intentioned in best sense of the term
but you are not those other people and
those other people of varying
consequences and they know of things
that you you don't understand and so on
on the on the on the on the tax thing I
like what my friend Edie crane said
about the famous quotation that is above
the door of the IRS Building in
Washington it's a quotation from justice
Oliver Wendell Holmes who said I think
is the exact location taxation is the
price you pay for civilization and Ed
crane says notice that's wrong taxation
is the price we pay for being
insufficiently civilized a civilization
is is when we cooperate peacefully to
help each other and so even if we grant
that there is some role for government
and once you granted some role for
government it's very difficult to not
see that there's some appropriate level
of Taxation to fund right that role for
government where much that may be true
that we need that it represents a
failure of us as a society to become
fully civilized we've somehow
not managed to figure out how to
cooperate peacefully and voluntarily in
those matters in ways that we have
managed discover how to cooperate
peacefully and voluntarily and doing
what we're doing here today and going to
the supermarket and the supermarket
dealing with the various of the
suppliers that that that it has none of
that is is funded with taxation it's all
funded with voluntary voluntary payments
that is civilization so I like the
notion that taxation is it's it's sort
of a measure of how little we are
civilized or how far we have to go to be
completely civilized to make sure we're
not killing each other to make sure
we're not yeah yeah
so all right so I want to get back to a
couple things you said there so first
okay I know that I know that the minimum
wage is a big one for you and even just
this morning I read another story about
how Bernie wants this $15 minimum wage
the antidote that I keep using or
antidote that I keep using is that I
keep trying traveling all over the
country right now and in almost every
Airport you go to fast food places and
they don't have people anymore they have
iPads yes now perhaps if you could pay
people less people would have jobs it
wouldn't be the greatest job in the
world but it would be the way it's
always worked now we are literally
replacing people with robots that may be
inevitable no matter what but to say
that you have to pay people again even
for my own business here I get people
offering to work for me for free all the
time I want to pay people daily and we
do pay all our people yeah but the idea
that the government would force me to
pay someone X amount seems completely
bananas yeah so the minimum wage puts
many low school workers out of jobs if a
teenager is not worth $7.25 per hour
employers who are not in the charity
business are not going to hire that
teenager at that price that teenager
will go without a job but go without a
job in the in the above-ground economy
might find a job paying more in the
underground economy which is a different
set of problems and so that is the major
unintended consequence of the minimum
wage there there are others but that
that's the big one
and if you know what people like Bernie
Sanders I mean because I speak to
proponents of the minimum wage all the
time
what most of them do they just stop the
analysis at that the surface Oh wouldn't
it be better to be paid $15 an hour and
simpler of course so this is they don't
want to get to the unintended
consequence yeah yeah but but I think
because I think because most of them
believe that they just have this image
of employers as being really rich highly
profitable operations and so if you
raise the minimum wage oh sure it is a
cost but it cost that's going to be
borne exclusively by employers but it's
a fact most low-skilled workers work in
highly competitive industries they work
in food retail you know they work at
lawn care they they work in in in in
supermarkets restaurants these are
highly competitive industries so there's
no big profit margin there so when you
raise the minimum wage it's not coming
out of the profits of the employers it
has to come out of some change in the
way the employers do their business
there's nothing wrong with automation of
course yeah but there's a there's a
proper amount of automation and if you
raise the minimum wage you get too much
automation because you put in too few
human workers and here's I just wanna
make this clear
here's another unintended consequence of
the minimum wage not only does it deny
income to those workers who lose their
jobs worse in most cases it denies those
workers what's even more valuable namely
the opportunity to get that first piece
of job experience and so the
sixteen-year-old who otherwise would
have gotten a job without the minimum
wage becomes a 17 year old or 18 year
old who's still a never employed person
whereas otherwise it would have had job
experience and so it swells artificially
swells the ranks of of unskilled workers
would there be a direct correlation then
that once you have this whole set of
people at this imaginary $15 minimum
wage they are also going to raise prices
on basic things right I mean is there a
direct correlation no no I mean prices
may rise a little bit cuz you get it you
know the economy's little bit less
efficient so you get a little bit less
output but the price increases aren't
aren't the the major problem the major
problem is employers will find ways to
satisfy
customers at slightly higher cost to the
employers but at huge cost to those
workers who who lose their jobs so when
you've talked to economists on the left
that disagree with you on this and I get
what you're saying that they're not
taking that next step I'm sure there's
someone out there that has made a sound
argument that you just disagree with it
so they are definitely so there is one
sound argument what one sound
theoretically one theoretically coherent
argument for the minimum wage without
and that is if employers have what's
called monopsony power then that can be
defined yes monopsony power it's like
monopoly power except so monopolist is
the only seller monopsonist is the only
buyer okay so if you're the only buyer
of low skilled workers in the market
right you as an employer you then can
and akise be easily shown you can keep
wages lower than they would otherwise be
too low and given that you it can be
then shown that if the government comes
in and sets a minimum wage right then
the employer will in fact pay the higher
minimum wage and no employees will be
harmed but it's a very very strict the
criteria that's a very very strict and
the idea that that wal-mart and
McDonald's and Burger King and KFC and
all the mom-and-pop restaurants and and
maid services and lawn care services
that we have throughout the United
States the idea that any one of these is
a Malone monopoly buyer of low-skilled
workers is just absurd alright so one of
the things that you write about a lot is
that the idea of middle-class stagnation
is actually wrong yes we hear this all
the time from politicians for I think my
whole life that I was ever caring about
politics it's always that the middle
class is shrinking and the extremes are
getting bigger
etc etc but you actually take a
different position yeah this
middle-class stagnation thesis is stated
as if it's an established fact with no
arguments against it it's just wrong I
think you were born in the mid 70s right
76 okay so according to this thesis it
was a it was right around that time mid
seventies when
that's okay right so I'm the American
middle class have been chugging along
upward it hits the mid 70s and then it's
been stagnant ever since so ordinary
Americans say so goes the thesis live no
better than ordinary Americans lived
when Gerald Ford was in the Oval Office
I think is crazy I mean I have i'm
unfortunate old enough to remember the
mid 1970s and although one's own
personal experiences shouldn't be a
basis for scientific conclusions they're
not irrelevant it may come from a
working-class US family I remember how
we lived in the 70s I don't know what
cars were like I mean what television
was like and what health care was like
things are a lot better today for
ordinary Americans and so I number years
ago just started looking into this this
thesis there are data that you can find
that the people who proposed as thesis
point to that that lends some
superficial credence to the thesis but
some here just some of the problems with
it with these data they adjust for
inflation in ways they vastly
overestimate the amount of inflation
that we've had since the mid 70s so mean
vastly under counting the growth in real
incomes since the 70s a lot of these
data will look at household incomes well
the side the typical population of the
American household has fallen since the
mid 1970s today it didn't sound like
much but today it's about 11 percent
lower than it was in 1975 but that's
actually pretty significant so the same
amount of income and a household now is
spread over fewer people and so the
individual people are richer meaning
we're just not having as many kids
that's we're not having as many kids we
we're becoming wealthier so that now
well maybe not in the last 10 years or
so but for much of this period younger
people have been able to move out of
their family their parents homes at a
younger age and start the households
younger older people are able to
continue to live by themselves rather
than move in with their with their
children the quality of goods and the
variety of goods and services that
American ordinary Americans have access
to today
is astonishing compared to what it was
just 40 years ago i sexually spend a lot
of time looking at you know catalogs
from the mid-1970s you know Sears
Roebuck catalog and then you can look at
you know Sears calm today and you can
look at the prices that would charge
back that course nominally they were
lower but then you just take those
prices and you divide them by the wage
that the average American earn back then
and do the same thing for the prices
today and divide it by the wage of the
average American earns today and what
you find in almost all cases is that the
amount of time it takes to work in order
to earn enough income to buy a pair of
jeans a shirt a washer and dryer and
your an airplane ticket is dramatically
less today America we don't have to work
as much today as we did back then in
order to get the things that make our
standard of living as high as it is so
did they just the people that believe in
this thing they just do a great sell job
I mean how did this meme how did this
idea get out there because you hear this
all the time everybody I mean this is
one of the few things that you hear on
both sides of the aisle yes yeah in fact
I uh yes I think the a lot Paul Krugman
says it all it says it all the time and
I think in a way kind of backfire and
people in the left if they keep saying
it and that I bleed it's one thing that
that helped drum up spa pew low support
for Donald Trump yeah you know
middle-class Americans been stagnating
so let's do something about it let's
electron it's an interesting
psychological thing there because I
think maybe most people think they're in
the middle like they probably think it
no matter what like they if they're not
destitute and if they're not you know
worth 20 million bucks you probably
think basically you're in the middle
yeah so it's a way of making it about
you even if it's actually not the case
yeah you question if I'm not sure
exactly exactly why it caught why this
myth caught on and it has held on with
such tenacity this myth has been going
around now for twenty years it started
in the mid 1990s yeah and it was
actually an economist he's now at
Southern Miss mu and Dallas he was at
the time at an economist at the Dallas
Fed guy named Mike Cox and he's the
first one who really started looking
into this well let's let's look at
various
measures of living standards let's look
at how much ordinary people are
consuming today compared to in the
mid-70s it's a cop
let's look at what happens when we
adjust for income using better inflation
adjusters come in what my cock's found
and I I my work is derivative of my
cock's
is that once you start doing this this
whole middle-class stagnation thing just
crumbles into dust it's just not true
it's not to say that there are no
problems it's not to say that the
middle-class wouldn't be even wealthier
had there not have there been better
policies in place whatever you think
those policies might be but it is to say
that it's just crazy to believe that an
ordinary American or an ordinary
American family in 2018 has a standard
of living that is indistinguishable from
that of an ordinary American family in
1975 yeah do you know what basically the
economics look like if you're considered
in the middle class right now like the
economic they're really like numbers
that you look at on both sides and go
alright that's what middle-class is
because I think that's part of the
problem it is this sort of amorphous
term yes yeah III don't believe that
there I'm you know the the the the
Census Bureau among others they will
divide household income into quintiles I
don't recall what those numbers are at
the moment but a common definition
should take the three middle quintile so
you get rid of the top 20% you were at
the bottom 20% you have the middle 60%
that's that's the middle class and you
know upper middle middle middle lower
middle but the Census Bureau does
something interesting from time to time
so it divides household income into
different categories less than 15,000
15,000 to 25,000 on and on up to like I
think 250,000 and above and it tracks
adjusting for inflation it tracks
household incomes over time and you can
in a perverse way find in these data
that the middle class in America is
disappearing right but it's disappearing
into the upper classes if you look at
the percentage of households in America
who are earning in the lowest
percentages right they're shrinking the
only the only categories in which the
percentage of households in the US are
increasing
or in the upper income levels and so the
actually I think the very lowest it
might have ticked up a little bit like
the less than 15,000 but in the great
middle they have fewer households
percentage-wise earning in those
categories today but more earning a
hundred thousand dollars annually and
above and so in one sense yes it's
freaky but it's getting richer
there's no evidence that we're getting
poor is no evidence that it's stagnating
yeah so we talked a little bit in an
ancillary way about taxes earlier so I'm
not an economist but I'm gonna lay out
what I think is sort of a fair tax
system that's consistent with all the
ideals that we've talked about here and
I want you to either I'm gonna blow your
mind or you're gonna tell me that I'm
way off so something like this this is
what I've said a couple times is that
I'm basically for attacks flat tax you
can get rid of exemptions let's say it's
about 15% but we can we can fiddle with
the numbers but let's about 15% I would
exempt everyone making let's say less
than like 40 grand maybe even 50 grand
so that they have a little more
disposable income that they can do
things which which I think is good for
them and good for the economy and then
just because I'm still I still a little
bit of a guilty liberal in me I would
even be willing to do some sort of
progressive tax if you're over say 10
million a year or something like that
even though I know it's not right and
I'm sure you can get rid of that by the
end of this conversation but there's
still a piece to me that says that but
basically saying that for the huge vast
majority of the country 15% little
exemptions maybe a little trickery on
the high end I think that's consistent
with the sort of classical liberal idea
of minimal involvement and an equality
of opportunity and what you're all
paying in and hopefully it would cause a
slimmer trimmer government yeah so so
some glimmering in your eye and said
earlier I think one of the
distinguishing features of an economist
has always asked us compared to what
right as compared to what we have now
okay that that's that's close to perfect
right I'll take it right yes compared to
what my actual ideal would be given that
we're going to have taxes it's not quite
my ideal I would indeed get rid of the
the progression yeah at that I don't
think part of me I think that still
exists
so the way I look at the way I look at
people who earn those kinds of incomes
assuming the ournament and most of them
do they earn these incomes in the market
that means that these people are
especially good at making life better
for ordinary Americans they're
especially good at creating jobs they're
especially good at increasing the value
of my 401 K but what would you say when
people say but they don't need 8 yachts
and helicopters and all that I would say
they earn it's theirs it's not up to me
to say what they they earn it's their
money I can't make an argument against
that I know it's theirs
it may look again you know the your
system is better than what we have now
but definitely if we're going to have
income taxation a flat tax and I'm
willing to have the exemption for the
lower lower incomes flat tax is the way
to go not only does it prevent a lot of
political chicanery you know messing
with brackets and but it's it is
economically the better system when you
tax all income earning activities at the
same rate then the relative prices of
different types of labour services stays
the same when you have progressive
taxation you create greater distortions
in the economy and that that makes us as
an accidents of this economy and makes
us all a little bit less wealthy than we
otherwise would be because the economy
has to deal with these distortions so
what do we do about spending because at
the end of the day that seems at least
when we're talking about this from a
government perspective that it's really
all about spending that you can tax out
the wazoo and regardless of whether that
tanks the economy or or fixes it or
whatever that that's almost irrelevant
if you just keep spending especially
because the amount of debt we have and
we know we're never gonna pay it back
which is why it's probably good that we
have a lot of bombs but that's a whole
other discussion you know because one
day if China calls in the debt you know
we're in a lot trouble but but how do
you rein in spending cuz this seems to
be the thing that all the Trump people
right they all thought he was gonna rein
in spending this is like the opposite
pack and and it's it's I think it's more
than ever before it is it is so I think
the big problem is I don't know how to
do it we can speculate about you're
changing the Constitution put in
constitutional balanced budget
amendments constitutional caps on
I'm skeptical of all of those things
government has many ways to get around
these B's paper tiger provisions the
problem is the problem is Americans
today look to government and they and
they basically you're spending other
people's money and so if you're spending
other people's money it's easy to spend
my my former colleague Russ Roberts had
a piece in The Wall Street Journal many
years ago entitled something like if
you're paying I'm having steak so
imagine you know imagine oh we all go to
a restaurant and you know the different
menu items right well if you go to a
restaurant and you and you're picking up
your part of the tab right you you you
may order steak but that's because it's
worthwhile to you and you'll have to pay
for it but you might if you have to pay
for you might network you might order a
less expensive dish but if it's gonna be
[ __ ] even so it couldn't be shared right
then based then the bulk of your extra
expenditure is shared with the people
you're going to dinner with and that's
true for every person at that dinner
right and so you wind up with this
bizarre circumstance where every person
acting rationally winds up ordering too
much winds up asking of the restaurant
too much we wind up asking of our
government too much but we have to pay
for the resources do not fall out of the
sky free they're coming from somewhere
and and because we're spending too much
we're taking resources where they would
be better used and putting them where
really none of us want them to be used
but we all wind them using them and I
know you said before that an antic total
story is not you know proof of a bigger
theory but as you're saying that it
reminds I don't think I've ever said
this publicly publicly before my brother
his bachelor party when I was a
struggling comic and I had no money you
know I may be fifty bucks in my pocket I
don't know I was the best man all his
friends were in banking and lawyers and
they had all had money big rollers we're
at a fancy one of the one fancy place
the Borgata in Atlantic City the one
fancy you know nice place in Atlantic
City and we're sitting around this huge
table at a really super fancy restaurant
and I'm and all the entrees are 80 90
hundred bucks and I'm looking around
like you know what am I going to do here
I was gonna get the chicken for maybe 50
bucks or something I'm sitting with my
my brothers one friend who also was kind
of struggling like I was and we're both
saying are we're gonna get the chicken
for 50 bucks we go around everyone's
gettin steak lobster steak lobster steak
lobster steak lobster it gets to my
friend Josh he turned he's the whole
time he's going on
the chicken fish the waitress says what
do you want he goes lobster and then I
just said steak like that like and it's
exactly what you're talking about you
suddenly lose concept of what's in your
pocket somehow it's gonna happen if the
bills gonna be shared then the the the
the the additional cost to you of
ordering steaks that is a tiny fraction
of the actual additional cost of the
steak and that's the problem with with
government today we have people in
Washington spending other people's money
for the benefit of yet other people and
when you do that you just get too much
too much spending we we've I don't know
a better way to say it doesn't sound
very economic I understand it but we've
lost the ethic of respecting other
people's property once government gets
money once government officials figure
out something that they fancy is is is
good and may or may not really be good
which doesn't mean necessarily it's
worthwhile but maybe a good project that
doesn't mean that therefore we should go
ahead and spend money on it there's an
insufficient connection between the
spending and the and and the and the
experience of the cost of the resources
that go into the spending how much are
you think of this do you think is not an
economic problem but a political problem
so that if a politician was to get this
right let's say there's some magical
politician out there who really
understands economics but he knows if he
goes to the Senate so I suspect Rand
Paul's kind of like this I think he
basically gets this man and he does
fight the best fight generally that I
think he can but that they guys want to
get reelected and saying to people we're
gonna spend less on you even though you
know it's it's the best thing we can do
for you actually it's gonna free you one
day and it's not gonna Bank the economy
and make us you know slaves to a foreign
nation all that it just doesn't work
politically because it's not the easy
answer of a bomb or I think it's exactly
right let's face it each politician has
a time frame that extends to the next
election right so in the case of members
of the House that's only two years case
of the president that's four senators
six that's not a long time frame
anything beyond that time frame is
irrelevant to that person politically
today or to make it relevant that person
has to have an
I think that is very rare and unusual
among politicians and people with that
ethic tend not to be not to succeed in
politics yeah a handful do manage to get
in but very few so you have people
without that ethic and they're just
looking toward the next election which
is that most again only no two years
away for a House member and so if the
bills coming to two and a half years
from now if the if whatever other costs
are gonna happen two and a half years
from now or or alternatively if if
taking some action that someone gonna
it's gonna have cost today but but huge
benefits no matter how huge two years
from now four years from now I'm not
gonna take it right because it's it that
will do nothing to get them past that
next hurdle which is getting elected
reelected so in a very depressing sense
or in a sort of dystopian future sense
are we in its certain way are we on a
pathway to destruction no matter what if
you think about it I mean if you take
that line of thinking long enough right
so we have a sort of weak political crew
dealing in ways that are the reverse of
how economically we can be successful
pretty right like pretty much always
going off the off the cliff yeah so I
despite all that I've said I remain
optimistic and I'm not I'm not sure why
right I feel the same way I remain
optimistic we we still have respect for
private property in the United States
we're still a very entrepreneurial
culture we still hold politicians to
some this is less now but it's there's
some level of responsibility I say that
I'm my libertarian friends are gonna
kill we were saying I think there's
something there's something there yeah
look the political problem has always
been there I think the cost US
Constitution in the past up until about
eighty years ago maybe did serve more as
a constraint that has largely been
shoved away but by and large we've still
prospered over the past 80 years almost
in spite of ourselves so this something
is something in the American mindset
there's something in our gumption
I don't want to sound like I'm not
rah-rah but but there's something about
this society of ours that remains
remains relatively open remains
relatively free property property rights
remain relatively secure I think we
still have something of a rule of law in
in place and what I've learned in the 40
or so years that I've been pondering
these issues is that a free society is
far more robust than I once believed it
to be which is not to excuse or justify
any of the abuses that it takes but it's
really robust and I have no good sense
of where the point is I don't believe
it's indestructible yeah but I have no
good sense of where the point is where
you hit that point and suddenly things
are destined to go into the into the
gutter we may be moving there now I have
a 21 year old son for his sake I
certainly hope we're not close to that
but my gosh if you look back to the
1930s I think things were even worse
than ideal wise government you know the
trend of government wise than they are
today and yet we did pretty well I'm
glad that you just said ideal wise
because one of the things that I focus
on here is talking about ideas they
matter that's that's the whole purpose
of what I do do you think that these
ideas related to freedom and the
individual and lays a Fair capitalism
and all the things that we've discussed
here are taking root again because
that's how I started you mentioned my
interview with Thomas all right before
we started and I sense it and again this
is I can only tell you what I'm
personally feeling and what what I the
feedback I get and all that but I said
to Thomas or to dr. Saul I said do you
realize the the Renaissance your work is
having and I think he's kind of he's
kind of just over it personally I think
he's proud of his work he should be yeah
and of course he should be but I think
just on a personal note he's kind of
like yeah I've been doing this for a
long time and that's great but I really
sense these things are taking root again
even though the mainstream media won't
let you really believe that and they
still will always elevate the people
that are pushing a lot of the more
socialist stuff instead of some people
with some so getting back to something I
said earlier I think it took a lot of
people by surprise in the late 1970s
when
the ideas for cutting marginal tax rates
dreg deregulation took hold and I think
that's because people like Milton
Friedman my my late colleague James
Buchanan had been working years earlier
in helping to Hayek and working years
early to make these ideas sound and and
accept it and they were in place and
when the crisis of the 70s hit those
ideas had an effect no one knows the
future the future is not destined to
repeat itself in the way that it did
then but there are a lot of really good
people are you you're doing great work
there are a lot of really creative young
people today push it you're refining
these ideas polishing ideas presenting
them to the general public and new and
more interesting ways and maybe it's a
Hope over experience maybe it hope over
I don't hope over reality but I actually
believe that these ideas are strong I
think they are appealing and there they
are out there and Wow
today in our May 19 may 2018 yeah we
can't see when they'll take root but I
think that they will in fact protect us
that's so that is the optimist in you
and I have that too because otherwise
how could we do what we do right I mean
if the answer if you had looked at me 10
minutes ago and said yeah pretty much we
got to go look the n1 it then I would
have drunk had some of the booze you
have yeah about behind it it was just so
drinking right now
yeah it's wait for Armageddon right yeah
no I I look I believe here's something
like that that I did not fully
appreciate 20 years ago that I do
appreciate now twenty years ago I was a
more hard-nosed economist and now ideas
are really irrelevant they don't matter
that much it's it's you know you know
the the institutional constraints I do
think institutional constraints matter
they're important but I've come to see
ideas as by far the single most
important constraint and fuel for a
society then largely affected by the
work of Deirdre McCloskey for thinking I
pad on and you one of my favorite you
interviewed Idris were
has influenced me greatly and her work
she's not the only one but she's done
more than any other modern economist to
make the case for the role of ideas and
I think she's correct she's correct in
that so in that you must be incredibly
hopeful then because I said I mean I
feel the idea revolutionize Montori with
Jordan Peterson now and I keeps going up
there and saying there's another the
right kind of revolution happening we're
not killing each other in the streets
yet and how does that get stopped by an
idea revolution yeah and you're so so at
the beginning I I mentioned that I came
to economics because I was impressed how
economics explained the gasoline
shortages of the 1970s so I don't
remember a few years ago you know
gasoline Bhama was an office gasoline
prices are rising people are complaining
here's the importance of idea ideas
there were there were no serious calls
even the in the Obama administration to
go back to 1970 style price caps on what
energy I took that is it huh as a good
sign and that's saying it what happened
in the future but I believe the reason
that was the case is because the
economists who expelled in Friedman I
think among others who explain the
devastating roles of price ceilings on
energy those ideas was still around it
was still out there still out there and
they prevented anyone who would propose
such policy seriously from being taken
seriously and so that though that notion
of returning to the 70's style price
caps just never got a hearing a few
years ago when gasoline prices were high
so that that's one data point that
supports our optimism yeah that that's
great I mean you know it takes a long
game right I mean that that's the point
it is a long game I want to talk a
little bit about regulation before
before we wrap up I had you may know him
the biology professor Brett Weinstein
who's been on the show and he said he's
a friend of mine he made an interesting
comment to me the other day I think
maybe he tweeted out and we discussed it
a little bit about well if you're if
you're taking the true libertarian
approach and you're against all
regulation well are you saying that you
want no regulation over the airlines for
example to have any safety regulations
or anything like that and what I we
didn't have a ton of time to get into
the conversation I said I said Brett
very quickly what I would say is I think
airlines are in the business
getting people from one place to another
and they do all their due diligence and
if the idea of a government bureaucrat
coming in to make sure that this little
thing is this way as if they have more
knowledge about it than the their life
people I find that to be pretty faulty
but but we sort of left the conversation
there yeah what do you what is the right
amount of regulation as a libertarian oh
I'm in favor of huge amounts of
regulation and I'm not being facetious I
love regulation I believe the best
regulator is the market
it's the competitive market it's
consumers being able to spend their
money as they choose and or not to spend
it as they choose it's the freedom of
different producers and entrepreneurs to
enter markets or leave markets as they
choose it's the competition among
producers that's where real regulation
comes from the market regulates
activities you're right about that there
are instance Airlines for example no one
has a stronger incentive to make sure
that a multi-million dollar piece of
machinery doesn't just willy-nilly fall
out of the sky then the owner of that
multi-million dollar piece of machinery
namely the airlines or the company that
they're there they're renting it from
and so the competition among the
airlines the the need for them to
protect their investments that is a
tremendous source of regulation and it's
a very nuanced source of regulation it
gets it right and it's not subject to
political control or political
manipulation so government so-called
government regulation is too often
actually deregulation in the worst sense
it's government relieving businesses of
the need to be as responsive to
consumers as they would otherwise need
to be so we call for example a
occupational licensing it has a form of
regulation well no it's a form of
deregulation it dreg it Dee regulates
the existing producers in the market
from having to be as responsive as they
otherwise would to consumers so for
example this would be like you have to
have a license to California yes yeah
and so if I if I'm a hair braider or a
barber or an electrician and if this if
the government prevents people from
entering in competition with me that
makes my life easier I don't have to be
and responsive to consumers I can charge
higher prices I could supply less high
quality services and so I am deregulated
in fact by that so-called regulation so
basically you would say it's the risk
you have to take to be free right so
that in other words that if you're an
electrician and I have somebody come
into my kitchen we had a little light
thing the other day not yes the guy was
licensed I guess because there's got to
be licensed what you're saying it's just
the risk that you have to take because
he doesn't want to come in here and burn
my house down nor do you want him to do
it right yeah yeah this is another
unintended consequence of so so-called
government regulation in that if people
come to depend on it too much they used
to assume whoever you call up you call
up and say you know I need some
electrical work done in my house well we
live in a state where electricians are
regulated so this God must be okay maybe
maybe not but if you knew that was up to
you to check first of all the market
supplies all these wonderful ways of
verifying quality so if anyone was free
to practice being an electrician you
would have easy access a consumer would
have easy access to various mechanisms
to rank various electricians by how
especially their Yelp and all the apps
and absolutely yeah so it's it's a it's
a total myth to think that the
government is more concerned about our
welfare and our property than we are
who's more concerned about your house
than you are who's more concerned about
your personal safety then health then
you are the government might pretend
that it's more concerned or that it
somehow has deeper insight to what is
best for you but I don't buy it I think
I think young children there they don't
know their interest as well as their
parents do but once you become an adult
the presumption must be that each of us
as an adult cares for and knows our best
interest much better than any third
party does reminded of something else
right now I think maybe I got too many
of my old economic theories from The
Simpsons because do you remember the
episode very early on with mr. burns at
the power plant and he's leaking you
know
nuclear waste into the river and they
get a three-eyed fish
and the whole idea being if you just let
business do what it wants it's gonna
pollute the river and you're gonna be
eating three-eyed fish but that's
completely the reverse of everything
you've said yeah so what an economist
would say to that is well you know there
are some areas where your actions as a
private citizen spill over onto a
innocent third party so they have no
input so reasonable people can disagree
about the proper role of government in
preventing pollution or or preventing
third party effects but so much
regulation has nothing to do with third
party effects it's simply to say you
know if you want to get your hair
braided you have to go to one of these
people that we approve you're not
allowed to go to that person over there
who does not yet have our approval oh
there's no third party effect here and a
surprising amount of regulation is of
that sort yeah I mean I remember when I
bought this house and you have to have
all the people come by and the
inspectors and everything and they're
looking for these little absurd things
that I'm talking with the Builder about
and well this has to be an inch this way
over here and bah-bah-bah and it's like
well there was no answer for it I mean a
couple times I said well why is that
yeah it's a regulation regulation is
some someone in sacramento's said this
is how it should be and and that's how
it is in everybody everybody so another
problem with government regulation is
that it's one size fits all and I don't
care how smart you are or how how much
experience you have in the past
particularly our highly dinah in our
highly dynamic economy things are always
changing different people have different
risk tolerances so one of my least
favorite regulators is the FDA there are
very few third-party effects with the
FDA the FDA is drug regulation affects
you and it prevents you in consultation
if you choose with your doctor and most
sensible people would consult with a
physician from choosing what level of
risks you're able to subject yourself to
in order to relieve yourself of pain or
to fend off him into death I don't
believe that's any bureaucrats business
but yours you may make a decision
different than differently than I do but
so what we all have different tastes we
all have different preferences
preferences all have different
tolerances I don't believe that it's the
government's position to say no no your
preference for risk is too great we are
not going to let you take this
experimental drug because we think it
might hurt you
I don't see that's the government's
business at all that's your business
right and you better get as educated as
possible I mean this is where I would
say it comes down to education and and
and but but who has a better incentive
to come in form than educator that
matter then you it's your life yeah
right and yes you can tell stories well
you know maybe you won't but I can tell
stories too well how do you know that
this bureaucrat over here is gonna do as
good a job I'm willing to bet that you
are much less likely to be a less
careful yeah with your life then this
guy or gal is with your life yeah all
right so since you said it was a long
game and I know how much Hayek has
influenced you and you write at Cafe
Hayek calm let's just what are the ideas
of Hayek I know we've actually explored
a lot of them here but if there was
something that I told you before that a
lot of my audience they go out and they
they get books after and they start
reading on all of this what are some of
the ideas of Hayek that you would like
to impart that society is vastly more
complex than we understand it to be
particularly a market-oriented global
society you know we talked about in be
talk about the labor market the amount
of trade you know the the GDP numbers
all these terms and numbers masks
enormous underlying complexities all the
action that makes our society work is
done at the local level and that that's
a core Hayekian insight and if you start
acting at this that they're at the
higher level the risk is that that you
will stamp out you'll you'll stop out
you'll smother these individual
adjustments at the local level that
actually but who's consequence is bubble
up to the top to to make it all work
there's a great Hayek he's not the most
quotable love of guys but it's a great
higher quotation I'm not going to get
exactly right but it goes something like
the curious task of the economist is to
remind men of how little they know about
what they imagine they can create right
so you know we can imagine if Bernie
Sanders imagines he can create a world
of everybody gets paid at least $15 an
hour there's other people imagine they
can create a world in which in which no
one is it dies because of you know a
drug overdose or well yeah well you
can't create that world it's far too
complex and that's the that's the
critical hijacking and inside the
world's really complex and therefore if
it's really complex we want to devolve
decision-making authority down to the
lowest possible level and not have
people who are slathered in hubris
making decisions for those of us on the
ground on that note I think you're an
excellent communicator of those ideas
that's what it's all about right and
it's reciprocated yeah thank you very
much and for more on Don check out cafe
Hayek com
[Music]
you